mein name ist da mit 2 1 den namen habe
ich von meinem daddy sagen hey mama und
date die sagen wir gehören hierher weil
wir unsere leute leben in die highschool
geht man um verprügelt haie oder
schwanger zu werden
da gehen wir nicht kein film der aus der
filmischen konzeption heraus eine größe
hat sondern der etwas mitreißendes hat
aus der geschichte selbst aus der
unmittelbarkeit ich muss verheimlichen
wer ich bin wenn ich zu hause bin kann
ich nicht so sagen wir auf den 10
wenn ich hier wäre nicht so wie in
badenheim dem begriff geht es um die
geschichte von star starker eine 16
jährige schülerin ausgaben hey das ist
ein schwarzes viertel ihre eltern
schicken sie allerdings auf eine weiße
privatschule und diese verwicklungen als
eine der wenigen vielleicht einzige
schwarze in dieser schule die sind schon
ein paar franken wert ihre geschichte
ist allerdings eine andere
es ist die geschichte eines wiedersehens
mit ihrem freund aus kindheitstagen
khalil auf einer party von der sie
gemeinsam wegfahren sie geraten in eine
verkehrskontrolle
khalil verhält sich ungeschickt muss man
sagen und wird bei der verkehrskontrolle
wie es leider viel viel viel zu oft
passiert von einem weißen polizisten
erschossen was aus dem wagen
er ist 16 und man sieht ihr merkt ihr an
indem wie sie wo sie steht dass sie
hilfe braucht
dass sie das vertrauen den schutz die
ermunterung die rettung durch ihre
familie und durch eine anwältin für eine
bürgerrechtsorganisation dass sie all
das braucht die merkt man an dass sie 16
ist das ja eine jugendliche ist dass sie
wachsen muss an dieser aufgabe die sie
sich letzten endes selbst setzt
gerechtigkeit für khalil zu fordern
dafür einzustehen ich weiß wofür steht
was glaubst du besitzt
ich denke es geht uns um uns um die
schwarzen um die armen um alle die ganz
unten seien ganze und die art wie sie
auf der einen seite dieses junge mädchen
ist diese junge frau ist und auf der
anderen seite eben die zentrale figur in
protesten die zu unruhen auswachsen
das ist toll erzählt dass es in tollen
bildern eingefangen und hat natürlich
den drive der straße den die musik der
straße das tempo des jugendbuchs und des
jugendheims ich kann nur einen
jugendlichen empfehlen da rein zu gehen
das ist ein thema was natürlich in der
amerikanischen zuspitzung waffengewalt
drogenkriminalität und so weiter weit
über das hinausgeht was wir hier kennen
aber das problem rassismus und das
problem alltagsrassismus eines dass wir
genauso kennen und dass dieser film auf
eine großartige weise vermittelt
wenn du bereit bist zu reden dann geht
lasst nicht zu dass man nicht zum
schweigen bringt ich habe mich nicht
ohne grund stark